I think we're celebrating recently a
very special anniversary yeah uh we tape
a little bit ahead um so I don't know
exactly when this is going to come out
but today uh is September
13th and my whole career in late night
started on September 13th 1993 so it's
been exactly 30 years Wow since I
started and it feels like a long cuz so
much has happened it feels like a long
time ago but I will always remember that
day yeah that we did our first
television show and a lot of young
people uh don't know or rightly don't
care but at the time it was kind of a um
who is this guy I was a complete unknown
and uh hadn't been on television and so
people were I think half the audience
was tuning in just to see someone try to
jump their motorcycle over a canyon and
fail so uh I have very fond memories of
the show it was a really fun first show
it was electrifying to get to do it you
were a baby I was 29 when I auditioned
that's crazy and then I had just turned
30 when I got the job and uh then we put
it together very quickly in a couple of
months and I do have to get this all
down on paper someday cuz it is a wild
story but uh with the help of really
talented funny people and got a good
crew together some of whom are still
with me today Jeff Ross still with me Mr
Frank Smiley still with me Paula Davis
Davis uh Gina um of course Batista and
and Andy I just I still see Andy almost
every day cuz he does his podcast here
in the building and so we see each other
a lot and Andy was out there with me uh
and he had been hired as a writer and
immediately I thought this guy I just
want him next to me because I'm I'm
going to on the nose cone of a rocket
into space I'm probably going to get
killed I'd like to have this funny guy
next to me and so that that was a
blessing so there was no original plan
for you to have a sidekick no there was
no original plan for anything and the
whole thing had to come together very
quickly uh but that first
show we worked really hard and uh Robert
Smigel my original headwriter he and I
had this vision of what we wanted and we
worked very hard and Jeff Ross was there
helping us make it happen and he was
instrumental in the whole
operation and we decided uh that we
wanted this very silly kind of sense of
humor and we worked so hard we had
pre-tapes we had everything just lined
up so we knew our first show was going
to be good we knew it was going to be
loaded with a lot of good stuff so
people subsequently said you must have
been terrified that day and I remember
thinking no I was just excited to get
going really yeah I was uh I was excited
I was so excited to get going because
the whole summer people were like who
the are you and that was my mom um
speaking of that you know how I heard
about you from my mom I was away at
college and she said this is the new guy
they're putting on Conan O'Brien and
then she really liked you she watched
the show that's nice I didn't have a TV
at college or I would have tuned in it
was a different time no one had it's
funny I go back to colleges now and they
have televisions and computer whatever I
just I I didn't have a of course uh
there weren't televisions when I went to
college um we had uh curv toop radios
but um anyway it was a really special
day and so it just funny to wake up
today and think H I had some texts from
people saying wow 30 30 years ago today
and that changed my life completely and
uh was great and um you know obviously
lots of ups and downs but just I
wouldn't change a thing AB absolutely
amazing and then I just keep thinking
about the different eras or sections so
went through that whole late night thing
and then Sona I don't meet you till
really the end of the late night thing
in the beginning of the Tonight Show mhm
thanks for your help with that
oh sounded like you were blaming me lot
people are lot okay oh I didn't know
that sorry well you were the one thing
that changed oh okay everything was
going along swimmingly then I came along
like I can help oh no look out um but no
uh you showed up and then that whole era
like the tour and everything at TBS was
and this podcast and meeting you mad I
me I know it sounds sappy but I cannot
believe my good fortune I just keep
meeting new people that challenge me in
different ways and I get to have more
and more fun it's just seems uh like I'm
off the charts blessed so half your life
you have been a figure a that would make
me 60 no oh I'm sorry oh yeah we're
putting out a press release that I am
one third of your life
44 oh we're putting it my my uh my
publicists had this idea this morning
I'm going to 44 now you want to go back
at the opening of this segment and say
we recorded this in
1998 yes I do okay well I think
President Clinton's doing a bang-up job
I also just want to take a second to say
no uh yeah I'm 60 now and I was yeah 29
when audition then 30 when we did the
show and yeah and it's so funny when I
look at clips now from that first show
or that first year of that first show I
can't believe they let that guy on
television he's so young and Goofy and
my hair was insane I don't know why but
I feel like you know you found your
stride very quickly too though I mean I
feel like you started in everyone just
started talking about you it's true I
heard about you from my mom but then it
was all my friend circles and we would
just watch and eat it up I would never
tell you probably enough what a fan I
was of you you have never mentioned it
I've mentioned it at least once talked
about this yeah maybe in my sleep it
came out no I really well you know what
it's interesting and I actually think
this is the way things should be but
most of what we heard about back then
because there wasn't an internet was we
just heard from TV critics who were not
happy and so we heard all this
negativity and the and the network
wasn't happy and so
we were only mostly just getting uh
negativity and then um I remember the
first summer that we you know we we made
it through the fall and this long dark
winter and a lot of criticism and uh it
was tough and then we made it to the
summer and kids got out of college and
they came to see the show live in rock
far Center and suddenly I'd walk out and
the A and and Robert Smigel I talked to
him about this he remembers it too
starting in June I'd walk out for the
monologue or for the warm-up and the
crowd would go crazy and I would think
is there someone behind me that they
want they want that they want to see but
I I had no we had no idea we had no idea
then of course they all went back to
school in the fall a do you think that
it would have you would have read stuff
if people talked about it cuz you're
very big on not reading no but I would
have it wouldn't maybe would have there
all these young performers today uh
comedians uh who were watching then who
tell me who are so established and good
and they tell me that they were watching
then and really liking it and my
reaction is always to a hater or melany
or Nick croll or any of these people why
didn't you tell me and they're like I
was a kid
idiot we didn't know I thought everyone
hated me and I did I sent
letters I shredded all the
letters if there wasn't cash in there I
shredded them but uh but 30 years that's
true truly remarkable and impressive so
congratulations and it is an amazing cuz
it won't I don't ever see anything like
that happening again where they just
take someone who no one has ever really
heard of and then make them host like a
storied franchise well also I think the
thing the television business has
changed so much that at the time now
there's so much television that you're
always you you can go home at night and
you can watch
10,000 uh television shows literally on
all these streaming services and they
can be populated with people you've
never heard of or you can go on the
computer and watch YouTube clips and
it's everybody you've never seen before
but this is back in this other era where
literally there's well there's two late
night shows and uh you know and now
there's going to be this there's this
third one so we're giving a third person
in America a chance who shall it be
what's the population of America about
340 million all right who should it be
Lauren Michaels what do you think I
think maybe con O'Brien done let's see
we'll need another
man yeah yeah and so it's just so weird
because it's crazy it's crazy I
shouldn't have had that chance and uh
got it and I've just been um and then as
you know Sona met my met Liza shooting a
remote on the show so that would never
have happened and you met your husband
because of the show show yeah and um I'm
marrying Matt gorley because he on the
podcast which wouldn't have happened if
it weren't for the show well other
people on the show married each other
and met because of the show like there's
there's babies because of the show oh
yeah also I think many many people made
babies at 12:30 at night back then
that's true because there was nothing
else so many people used to say I
watched you last night cuz I was up
I'd say what an awful phrase
that's too
much that's the key to your longevity is
that you're an aphrodesiac and then you
made another generation of
people that hold to you they made it
very clear they were having sex when a
cat stepped on the remote and the TV
came
on God damn it I can't finish why cuz
that idiot's on hair's going every which
way he's jerking around he's talking too
much his voice is weird that comedy's
abrasive and strange and this is you
talking with an
accent all right well very uh feel very
fortunate today to just have to to have
been around for this ride and now
goodbye for oh wait that was unforeseen
well I it just felt like I should ride
off now no no no okay I'll sck around
keep going all right I have a house to
off I've seen it it's a nice
house